einen schönen guten tag aus hagen und
herzlich willkommen zu dieser online
vorlesung entdecke ihnen gerne ein
bisschen berichten möchte aus meiner
forschung der letzten jahre
da habe ich mich insbesondere mit
religiösen praktiken beschäftigt und
zwar mit solchen religiösen praktiken
die auch heute noch oder wieder
soziologe gerne sagt die in unserer spät
modernen gesellschaft noch praktiziert
werden ja die auch heute noch auf
gesellschaftliche resonanz stoßen die
anschlussfähig sind die gelebt werden
und die mitunter sogar an popularität
gewinnen
das nämlich trifft ja lange nicht auf
alle kennzahlen des religiösen feldes zu
wenn sie beispielsweise an kirchen mit
wirtschaftszahlen in deutschland denken
dann sehen wir da einen sehr deutlichen
rückläufigen trend ja in den 1950 er
jahren war das noch so dass annähernd 95
prozent der deutschen bevölkerung
mitglied der katholischen oder
evangelischen kirche waren und seitdem
gehen die kirchenmitgliedschaft quoten
kontinuierlich zurück heute sind noch
ungefähr 53 prozent der deutschen
bevölkerung mitglied der katholischen
oder der evangelischen kirche
interessanten statistischen effekt sehen
sie dann übrigens im jahr 1990 ja das
ist zurückzuführen auf die deutsche
wiedervereinigung und ein zeichen für
dieses was man säkulares erbe der ddr
nennt ja die ddr war ja sehr erfolgreich
darin kirchenmitgliedschaft zahlen zu
senken und das hat sich dann im zuge der
deutschen wiedervereinigung eben auch
auf die gesamtdeutschen quoten
ausgewirkt ein bisschen stabile übrigens
als die kirchenmitgliedschaft sein ist
die religiöse selbsteinschätzung also
regelmäßig fragt man den einschlägigen
server ist die menschen würden sie sich
selbst als religiösen menschen
bezeichnen und auf diese frage haben im
jahr 1999 noch 55,8 prozent mit ja
geantwortet und die neuesten zahlen die
uns diesbezüglich vorliegen stammen aus
dem jahr 2017
und da haben noch 53,5 prozent gesagt ja
ich würde mich selbst als religiösen
menschen beschreiben
wichtig für uns aber sind ja vor allem
eben religiöse praktiken und wenn man
dieses wort hört dann denkt man dann
denke ich erst mal an zwei kern
praktiken ja und zwei traditionelle
religiöse kern praktiken nämlich einmal
an den gottesdienstbesuch
und wenn wir dann mal schauen also wie
viele leute besuchen eigentlich
regelmäßig und damit meine ich
mindestens einmal im monat einen
gottesdienst dann waren das im jahr 1990
noch 30,4 prozent im jahr 2017
aber nur noch 19,3 prozent und die
zweite zentrale religiöse kern praktisch
wäre sicherlich das beten und wenn wir
hier mal schauen wie viele leute beten
eigentlich regelmäßig und das heißt
jetzt dem fall dieses diagramms wie
viele leute beten mindestens einmal in
der woche
so war das im jahr 1999 noch 35,8
prozent im jahr 2017 aber nur noch 28,3
prozent
ja also die meisten kennzahlen des
religiösen feldes in deutschland sind
rückläufig und das wird ja vor allem von
sogenannten säkularisierung thesen
aufgegriffen die also argumentieren
religion verliert in unserer modernen
gesellschaft immer mehr an bedeutung und
zwar so die argumentation der
säkularisierung thesen weil religion in
einem letztlich unauflöslichen
spannungsverhältnis stünde zu den
zentralen merkmale moderner
gesellschaften wenn verschiedenen
anschlag gebracht
diskutiert wird zum beispiel die
demokratisierung ja unsere modernen
gesellschaften sind demokratisch
ausgelegt und da passt so eine religiöse
organisation ja also die das leben ihrer
mitglieder umfänglich zu regulieren
sucht und zwar ohne explizit
demokratische abstimmungsprozesse nicht
so richtig ins bild man denkt aber zum
beispiel auch an die wohlstand
steigerung moderner gesellschaften weil
man aus studien weiß ja dass hier
wohlhabende eine gesellschaft desto
weniger religiös oder man denkt zum
beispiel auch an urbanisierung insofern
das also in unserem spätmodernen leben
das ja zu einem großen teil heute in
großstädten statt findet ja die
integration in religionsgemeinschaften
nicht mehr so einen stellenwert hat wie
das vielleicht im ländlichen raum der
fall sein mag ja also solche kennzahlen
moderner gesellschaften nimmt man her
oder solche merkmale moderner
gesellschaften und sagt die passen
letztlich nicht zu religion wie wir sie
bisher kennen und deswegen argument
argumentieren die säkularisierung thesen
ja dass mit zunehmender modernisierung
einer gesellschaft religion mehr und
mehr an bedeutung verliert und diese
these die säkularisierung these ist
freilich nicht ohne kritik geblieben
ja sie wurde von thomas luckmann und
robert bella schon relativ früh als
moderner mythos kritisiert und im
heutigen religion soziologischen diskurs
sind es also vor allem drei argumente
die kritisch angebracht werden gegen die
säkularisierung these
da ist zum einen ihr eurozentrismus ja
also denn diese entwicklung die wir
gerade gesehen haben also beispielsweise
der rückgang der kirchenmitgliedschaft
zahlen oder das seltenere praktizieren
religiöser kern praktiken
das sehen wir natürlich hier bei uns in
deutschland und wir sehen es auch in
einer ganzen reihe europäischer länder
wohlgemerkt mit großen unterschieden
zwischen westeuropa und osteuropa auch
zwischen süd europa und nordeuropa wir
sehen es aber lange nicht fällt weit ja
also insbesondere wenn sie in südamerika
denken oder wenn sie an asien denken
dann stellt sich die lage natürlich ganz
anders da ja und wenn wir beispielsweise
mai die katholische kirche neben mir hat
dann sprechen wir hier bei uns in
deutschland oder in westeuropa immer
davon dass sie an mitgliedern verliert
wenn man dann allerdings mal weltweit
schaut dann ist es so dass auch in den
letzten jahren die katholische kirche an
mitgliedern gewonnen hat ja und zwar
stärker als die weltbevölkerung
insgesamt gewachsen ist also
säkularisierung thesen ist immer ein
gewisser eurozentrismus im herren
der zweite kritikpunkt an dieser these
vom gesellschaftlichen bedeutungsverlust
von religion der bezieht sich auf diese
theologie ja ich sagte ja eben letztlich
sagt säkularisierung theorie oder
säkularisierung thesen sagen je moderner
die gesellschaft desto weniger religiös
ist sie jetzt haben wir aber das habe
ich ja gerade schon gesagt wenn man
verschiedene gesellschaften miteinander
vergleicht sehr unterschiedliche
religiöse lagen in der gesellschaft und
auch in der historischen entwicklung
sehen wir immer einen sehr
unterschiedlichen gesellschaftlichen
stellenwert von religion also so dass
man letztlich eher von nichtlinearen
auch von multiplen säkularisierung
prozessen ausgehen kann und nicht von
einem immer weiter fortschreitenden
bedeutungsverlust von religion denn zu
ende gedacht hieße das ja wenn unsere
gesellschaft einmal wirklich ihre
modernisierung abgeschlossen hat dann
hat religion völlig an bedeutung
verloren und ein dritter kritikpunkt der
in stellung gebracht wird gegen die
säkularisierung these ist dieses
spannungsverhältnis zwischen modernen
religionen also da gibt es kolleginnen
und kollegen die argumentieren ja aber
auch unsere heutige zeit also auch
unsere spätmoderne gesellschaft ist doch
religions- produktiv also sie bringt
neue formen hervor sei religiös
begründete ideologien seines neue und
dann vor allem stärker individualisierte
und vom einzelnen menschen selbst
bestimmte form von religion ja und
diesen befund dass wir also einerseits
im religiösen feldes zu tun haben
mit einem bedeutungsverlust religiöser
kern praktiken ja mit einem sinkenden
organisationsgrad in bezug vor allen
dingen auf die christlichen kirchen
dass wir aber andererseits auch neue
formen individueller
religion sehen deshalb ulrich becker
einmal als das säkularisierung paradox
moderner gesellschaften bezeichnet
und ich möchte heute jetzt einen vierten
wenn man so will kritischen punkt
gegenüber der säkularisierung these
hervorheben nämlich dass es offenbar
bestimmte religiöse praktiken gibt die
auch heute noch an bedeutung gewinnen
wie jedenfalls an popularität gewinnen
und von mehr und mehr menschen
praktiziert werden
zwei beispiele habe ich mitgebracht
nämlich zum einen das pilgern auf den
jakobswegen das ist das linke diagramm
das zeigt die in santiago de compostela
in galicien in spanien also am zielort
der jakobswege registrierten pilgerinnen
und pilger und da sehen wir schon seit
den 1990 er jahren einen frappierenden
fortwährenden anstieg der pilger zahl
nervös im jahr 2020 jetzt erst mal einen
sehr deutlichen corona bedingten
einbruch sehen aber auch für die
folgejahre jahr rechne die galicische
regionalregierung mit einem anstieg der
bürger zahlen von rund acht prozent per
anno und hier reden wir nur von den
jakobsweg pilgern gibt es natürlich auch
anderorts und vor allen dingen auch in
anderen weltreligionen wenn sie zum
beispiel mal an die islamische
pilgerfahrt nach mekka die hadsch denken
ja die daher ein sehr hohen
theologischen stellenwert hat als eine
der fünf säulen des islam das andere
diagramm das sagt uns etwas über eine
andere religiöse praktik von der ich
ihnen heute erzählen möchte nämlich über
das fasten
da wissen wir was die daten angeht sehr
wenig ich habe ihnen hier mitgebracht
eine eine umfrage einer deutschen
krankenkasse die schon seit dem jahr
2012 also jedes jahr fragt wie viele
menschen in deutschland denn während der
fastenzeit fasten und da sehen sie im
jahr 2012 war das gut die hälfte der
deutschen bevölkerung die schon mal
gefastet hat
im jahr 2020 waren das dann gute 60
prozent also hier haben nicht so einen
deutlichen anstieg aber einen leichten
anstieg und eigentlich er also eine
stabile quote der menschen die auch
heute tatsächlich auch fasten
ja und mit diesen beiden religiösen
praktiken möchte ich mich heute
beschäftigen oder tue das überhaupt in
meiner forschung weil ich glaube dass
das sinn macht haben die
religionssoziologie hat sich in den
letzten jahren und jahrzehnten doch sehr
stark konzentriert auf eben jene formen
von religionen die ich ihn am anfang
gezeigt also die form die eher
rückläufig sind wo die quoten nach unten
weisen und ich möchte da eigentlich
einen anderen weg gehen und mal explizit
die form und praktiken in den blick
nehmen wo die kurven nach oben weisen
weil ich glaube dass wir daraus einiges
lernen können ja wir können daraus etwas
lernen über die bedingungen unter denen
religion auch heute noch funktionieren
kann ja über die voraussetzungen die
erfüllt sein müssen damit religion in
modernen gesellschaften erfolg haben
kann oder noch allgemeiner formuliert
ich denke wir können daraus das ein oder
andere darüber lernen wie religion in
der späten moderne funktioniert und mit
diesen beiden praktiken möchte ich mich
heute gerne in vier schritten mit ihnen
beschäftigen in den ersten beiden
schritten die auch den hauptteil dieser
vorlesung darstellen werden möchte ich
mich eben mit den pilgern und dem fasten
auseinandersetzen ich werde ihnen zwei
meiner eigenen studien vorstellen und
ihnen jeweils sagen welche daten da auf
welche weise erhoben wurden und was ich
für die zentralen befunde halte und wie
ich die religion soziologisch einordnen
würde
in einem dritten schritt müssen wir dann
denke ich noch mal einen schritt
zurücktreten
und wenn man so will auch durchaus
selbstkritisch ja mal die frage
diskutieren haben wir es denn beim
pilgern und fasten überhaupt mit
religion oder mit religiösen praktisch
zu tun ursprünglich ist das sicherlich
ganz fraglos der fall von ihrem ursprung
her ist sowohl das begann als auch das
fasten ganz eindeutig religiös aber
vielleicht hat es sich im zuge der
modernisierung ja so stark gewandelt
dass es heute schwieriger ist das noch
als religiöse praktiken zu beschreiben
die frage ist gar nicht so leicht zu
beantworten weil man sich eher uneinig
ist in den sozialwissenschaften was denn
überhaupt religion ist das möchte ich
also gerne reflektieren
aber sie werden es sich denken können
ich werde dann im vierten schritt im
fazit zu dem schluss kommen dass ich
sowohl das pilgern als auch das fasten
auch in der heute gelebten form als
religiöse praktiken greifen würde und
diese vorlesung schließen möchte ich
dann mit einer these also die vielleicht
einen erklärungs beitrag leisten kann zu
der frage warum sind es eigentlich warum
sind eigentlich genau diese beiden
praktiken so erfolgreich während eben
viele andere religiöse praktiken heute
selten praktiziert werden
beginnen wir also mit dem ersten
beispiel mit dem pilgern
da ist es so dass mit dieser vielzahl
der pilgernden diese eben in der
statistik gesehen haben natürlich auch
eine vielzahl von pilger motiven von
motivation einher geht die der
pilgerfahrt der menschen zugrunde liegen
ja ich habe ihnen hier mal daten
mitgebracht von markus kampka und julia
reuter die haben im jahr 2010 also die
eigentlich bis heute größte
sozialwissenschaftliche studie auf den
jakobswegen durchgeführt und haben da
unter anderem eben die leute gefragt
warum sie denn dann gehen sie sehen erst
mal das sind viele verschiedene motive
was vielleicht auch schon so ein erster
befund sein kann
ich mag die jetzt auch gar nicht im
einzelnen mit ihnen durchgehen sondern
vielleicht ein zwei schlaglichter werfen
ich denke was als erstes auffällt wenn
man diese motiv liste und die quoten mit
der die motive genannt werden anschaut
ist ganz oben stehen selbstbezug
subjekt bezogene motivation ja also da
geht es um den oder die pilgernde selbst
das meistgenannte motiv von mehr als der
hälfte der befragten ist ich pilgere um
zu mir selbst zu finden
es folgen dann sowas wie ausklinken aus
dem alltag stille genießen spirituelle
atmosphäre führen sagen mehr als ein
drittel der befragten das ist
interessant die menschen wollen die
natur genießen die morgen draußen
wir wollen die landschaften genießen
also da geht es um die pilgernden selbst
deutlich seltener genannt werden von den
befragten dann klassische religiöse
pilger motivation ja also es ist nicht
mal ein viertel das expressis verbis
sagt ich billigere aus religiösen
gründen oder ich möchte andere
religionen kennenlernen ja nur sehr
wenige nämlich gut 16 prozent der
befragten sagen
außerdem ich möchte buße vor gott tun ja
also das sieht man sehr selten so eine
explizite religiöse motivation und noch
seltener sieht man dann motive dir ein
touristischer natur sind oder die
sportliche ambitionen zum ausdruck
bringen ein ganz ganz interessant
übrigens auch ist dass das zweit letzt
genannte motiv also dass am
zweitwenigsten genannte motiv ist dass
pilger ziel erreichen zu wollen
ja also offenbar scheint es den pilgern
auf den jakobswegen er so zu gehen dass
für sie der weg ja man könnte vielleicht
hinzufügen der weg zu sich selbst das
ziel der pilgerfahrt ist und nicht so
sehr der zielort santiago de compostela
was gamper und reuter in ihrer forschung
jetzt gemacht haben ist dieses breite
spektrum von pilger motivation ein wenig
zu bündeln sie haben ein faktoren
analyse gemacht dass ein statistisches
verfahren um mal
zuschauen ja also welche motive hängen
eigentlich miteinander zusammen und auf
diese weise konnten sie fünf gruppen von
pilgernden identifizieren ja da ist
zunächst einmal das was die touri kino
nennen also der rein touristisch
motivierte bürger der einfach urlaub
machen möchte auf dem jakobsweg andere
kulturen kennenlernen sehenswürdigkeiten
besichtigen et cetera pp
da ist der rennsport pilger dem es darum
geht möglichst viel jeden tag zu pilgern
und das ziel zu erreichen
und da ist der spaß pilger ja der andere
leute kennen lernen möchte er auf dem
jakobsweg feiern möchte
diese drei gruppen rein touristische
pilger sport pilger und spaß bürger um
die geht es jetzt heute eben nicht so
sehr für unsere zwecke interessanter
sind die beiden nun folgen und gruppen
und da konnten gamper und reuter
zunächst mal den klassischen religiösen
den traditionell religiösen pilgernden
identifizieren ja leute mit gefestigten
auch meist an eine konfession gebundenen
glauben die ihre pilgerschaft als
glaubensbekenntnis begreifen ja die
damit bestimmte zwecke verfolgen nämlich
danksagung gegenüber gott bestellung an
gott und ähnliche motive
das ist übrigens die kleinste unter
diesen fünf pilgergruppen die mit
abstand größte der fünf gruppen das sind
dann aber das was kamper und reuter die
post pilger nennen ja das sind eben die
leute die vor allem die subjekt
bezogenen motivation nennen
und diese post pilgernden deren
religiosität zeichnet sich eher durch
eine sinnsuche aus vor allem auch durch
eine selbstbestimmung ihre religiosität
die sind relativ unabhängig von
religiösen organisationen wie den
kirchen und weil es eben die größte
dieser fünf pilgergruppen ist sprechen
gamper und reiter davon dass es sich bei
den post bürgern denn eigentlich um den
prototyp des spätmoderne pilgers handelt
und sie gehen noch einen schritt weiter
und sagen eigentlich ist es sogar
ein prototyp für so ein später modernes
bedürfnis nach individuell ausgestaltete
religiösität auch deshalb sollten wir
uns diese gruppe mal ein bisschen
genauer anschauen und das möchte ich
gerne mit ihnen machen anhand einiger
eigener daten da hat ebenfalls im jahr
2010 mein kollege christian kurth auf
dem jakobsweg daten erhoben auf dem
camino francés das ist dieser hauptweg
von sortierte portner santiago de
compostela 800 kilometer lang
ja da hat pilgern der interviewt hat 30
sogenannte native interviews geführt
also das sind sehr ausführliche
biografische interviews also wo die
interviewpartnerinnen und
interviewpartner sehr ausführlich raum
bekommen
stundenlang ihre lebensgeschichte zu
erzählen so dass man dann als forscherin
oder als forscher rekonstruieren kann
also welche punkte in diesen
lebensgeschichten ja welche
biografischen situation haben die
pilgerschaft eigentlich initiiert und
weil es uns darum ging also eben nicht
diese sport und spaß pilger und die
touristischen pilger zu erfassen sondern
heben diese diese beiden letzten gruppen
haben wir so ein paar einschränkungen
des samples gemacht ja also zum beispiel
wurden nur allein pilgernde interviewt
also niemand der im reisegruppen
unterwegs mal beispielsweise und nur
solche die schon über einen längeren
zeitraum gepilgert sind nämlich
mindestens 400 kilometer also die hälfte
des camino francés und diese daten haben
wir dann ausgewertet und haben eine
typologie erstellen können von fünf
pilger typen ja innerhalb dieser gruppe
der post pilgernden wenn man ihre
biografien rekonstruiert kann man
nämlich sehen dass diese menschen
pilgern gehen entweder um ihr leben zu
bilanzieren oder um eine lebenskrise zu
verarbeiten um eine auszeit
aus ihrem mitunter stressigen alltag zu
nehmen um ihr leben neu zu starten oder
um biografische übergänge rituell zu
begleiten und das spannende an dieser
studie und ihrem ergebnis ist dass sich
diese fünf typen anhand von drei
dimensionen ziemlich trennscharf
voneinander abgrenzen lassen
da alle fünf typen in je spezifischer
weise ja mit anderen pilgernden
kommunizieren denn je spezifischer weise
diese körperlichen anstrengungen einer
pilgerschaft deuten und in je
spezifischer weise ein verhältnis zu
ihrem heimischen sozialen umfeld haben
darauf möchte ich jetzt aber auf dieser
typologie an sich nicht mehr im detail
eingehen da haben christian kurth und
ich an vielen anderen stellen schon
darüber vorgetragen oder auch das eine
oder andere darüber geschrieben sondern
ich würde gerne jetzt den fokus darauf
legen zu schauen wo zeigt sich denn bei
diesen fünf typen der post präsidentin
religiosität wenn wir da mal mit den
bilanzieren anfangen also älteren
menschen ja die auf den jakobsweg gehen
um auf ihr leben zurück zu schauen und
die die stille suchen eben um ihr leben
reflektieren und bilanzieren zu können
bei den sehen wir zum beispiel einen
interessanten aspekt von religiosität
bilanzierungs beginnende nämlich fühlen
sich häufig auf den jakobsweg berufen
ich will ihnen das mal anhand von zwei
kurzen beispielen und anhand von zwei
interview zitaten zeigen ja wir haben
einerseits zu tun mit einem 70 jährigen
katholischen rentner aus deutschland der
sagt im interview ich muss mittlerweile
sagen es also die pilgerfahrt die
pilgerfahrt ist kein wunsch gewesen
sondern es ist ein ruf gewesen
am anfang war der wunsch den weg zu
gehen aber immer mehr und mehr biss zu
sein ruf gebrochen und ganz ähnliches
sagt uns ein 78 jähriger amerikaner ein
ehemaliger us-soldat methodist er sagt
church and state and came out one thing
to do was wir neben diesem gefühl des
prüfen seien auch häufig sehen bei
bilanzierungs pilgern ist dass es ihnen
um buße geht ja buße für sündhaft das
verhalten in ihrer vergangenheit ja sie
reflektieren ja eben ihr leben unter
stoßen sind natürlich auch dinge an die
sie heute vielleicht anders sehen die
sie heute als fehler einschätzen dafür
wollen sie buße tun sie wollen um
vergebung bitten
der deutsche rentner beschreibt es so es
gibt natürlich dinge die man falsch
gemacht hat
die man bereut und ich bitte um
vergebung ich denke viel an die
stationen in meinem leben zurück und
schon die erfahrungen und für die
negativen dann nehme ich gerne die eine
oder andere blase oder irgendwelche
gelenkschmerzen in kauf sei es als buße
oder wie auch immer
und der amerikaner sagt waters ergebnis
im ernst ging vor vergiftet mainka - spd
asking for ergebnis in bonn you get what
you want to continue to bei den krisen
pilgern also die in jüngerer
vergangenheit eine lebenskrise
durchlitten haben die sie jetzt auf dem
jakobsweg verarbeiten wollen da sehen
wir religiosität beispielsweise daran
dass pilgern die sehr häufig die
erlebnisse die sie auf dem pilgerweg
haben als wunder deuten hier zum
beispiel einen ganz kurzen interview
auszug von einer 46-jährigen
katholischen heilpraktikerin
sie beschreibt folgendes sehen wir waren
in einer gottverlassenen gegend
ich weiß noch es war kalt und so ein
grauer nebliger tag ich habe wahnsinnig
hunger gehabt und plötzlich steht eine
frau und bietet die einfach selbst
gebacken ist an
in der stadt denkst du nicht darüber
nach weil da gibt's pizza hut und
mcdonald's und bäckerei an jeder ecke
aber hier kommst du vielleicht mal in
die verlegenheit
du wirklich hunger hast und just in dem
moment steht eine ältere frau die gerade
frische pancakes gemacht hatte das ist
ein wunder dass empfindest du in dem
moment als ein geschenk gottes und eine
andere beschreibung noch wo es um den
austausch über die krisenerfahrung geht
die ja sehr wichtig ist nur für diese
krisen und krisen pilger ja es wichtig
sich stark mit anderen pilgern den
auszutauschen weil sie dann feststellen
ja es geht auch anderen menschen so da
ähnlich wie mir und die darin trost
finden also ganz im gegensatz zu diesen
bilanzierungs pilgern und kommunizieren
krisen begann sehr stark mit anderen
pilgern und hier ein zitat von einer 51
jährigen deutschen krankenschwester
ebenfalls katholisch sozialisiert die
sagt das fing der erste an zu weinen und
hat von seinen problemen gesprochen dann
hat der nächste von seinen problemen
erzählt und dann ging das reihum bei dem
einen ist der vater krank der andere ist
geschieden
also jeder hat eigentlich seinen grund
warum er hier ist die these die wir
aufgestellt haben die keiner beantworten
konnte wer hat uns überhaupt zu dieser
zeit hierhin geschickt hat uns jemand
geschickt und da sind wir alle davon
ausgegangen dass wir von irgend jemandem
geführt und geschickt werden dritter
typus waren die auszeit pilgernden also
solche die in ihrem heimischen umfeld in
ihrem alltag zu hause viel stress haben
die davon zurücktreten sich eine auszeit
nehmen wollen
für die ist zunächst mal die erfahrung
einer wartungsfreien gemeinschaft mit
den anderen pilgern auf dem jakobsweg
eine ganz neue und beeindruckende
erfahrung also man wird doch sehr
schnell aufgenommen in pilger gemein
haften so wie es hier überhaupt typisch
ist ja für die sehr breit und sehr
niederschwellig integrierenden
religionsgemeinschaften auch jenseits
des jakobswegs und die finden wir sehr
häufig unter den pilgern denn diese
erwartungs freien gemeinschaften ein 29
jähriger journalist beschreibt das
folgendermaßen er sagt jeder lässt jeden
so wie er ist und wenn man sich halt
gerade nichts zu erzählen hat und muss
man auch nicht krampfhaft ein thema
suchen auch der andere tut das nicht
sondern man schweigt dann halt einfach
und das ist eigentlich ganz angenehm und
was auszeit pilgernde genau wie alle
anderen pilger typen häufig tun es sie
nutzen wenn sie das möchten ja oder
genauer gesagt in den momenten in denen
sie das möchte bestimmte kirchliche
angebote vor allen dingen diese pilger
andachten ja die gibt es eigentlich auch
in diesen ganzen kleinen orten entlang
des jakobswegs sehr regelmäßig also
eigentlich jeden abend ja findet da in
den kirchen eine andacht statt bei der
die pilgernden dann meist auch einen
pilger segen gespendet kriegen und es
beschreibt eine 46-jährige
konfessionslose mediengestalterin
folgendermaßen sie sagt ich gehe hier
auch zum messe und findet die kirchen
hier schön weil man wirklich ein teil
ist ob man dazu gehört ob man in diesem
ort lebt oder nicht
ich habe hier schon zweimal das
abendmahl bekommen und der pastor kommt
und gibt jedem die hand sogar obwohl ich
gar nicht zur gemeinde gehöre
und dann gibt jeder bürger jedem die
hand ich kenne so was nicht aber ich
finde es sehr beeindruckend
das finde ich wunderbar
auch beim neustart pilgerin neustart
dann also die die ihr leben sagen wir ja
über den haufen geworfen die selbst
einen biografischen bruch initiiert
haben die ihren job gekündigt haben ihre
partnerin verlassen haben oder ähnliches
auch da zeigt sich religiosität in ganz
vielfältiger form zum beispiel auch
anhand von kirchen besuchen und damit
meine ich jetzt nicht so sehr wie gerade
den besuch von gottesdiensten sondern
den besuch des ortes kirche ja kirche
als eine gelegenheit der einkehr als ein
meditationsraum ein 30-jähriger
konfessionsloser dreher den interviewt
haben der sagt zb ich gehe auch oft in
kirchen auf dem weg setzte mich fünf
oder zehn minuten hin genießt die ruhe
denkt nach ab auch mein gebet zu hause
bin ich nie in der kirche habe das
zuhause nie gemacht und ich glaube wenn
ich wieder zu hause bin dass sich das
auch ab und zu mal machen werde
mal in die kirche gehen und ein anderer
aspekt von religion denen wir sehr
häufig gesehen haben in den interviews
mit dem pilgernden das ist eine
erzählung in form von gleichnissen ja
mal ein beispiel mitgebracht von einem
60-jährigen deutschen rentner
evangelisch er sagt mir ist das bild vom
adler in den sinn gekommen der hasler
steigt gegen den wind wenn der radler
steigen will braucht dagegen wünscht er
muss sich den gegenden stellen und er
muss den gegenwind annehmen als geschenk
das ihm die möglichkeit gibt kraft und
größe zu entfalten und höhe zu gewinnen
und so habe ich das auch übertragen auf
meine verhältnisse dass ich gesagt habe
ich wollte diesen gegenwind eigentlich
nicht haben wirklich nicht aber wo er
jetzt da ist kann ich nicht davor
weglaufen
ich muss ihn nutzen darüber habe ich
dann den ganzen tag nachgedacht wenn ich
da am berg lebte und versuchte schritt
für schritt voranzukommen habe ich mich
mit dem adler verglichen eine ganz
banale
aber wichtige erkenntnisse also dieser
art und weise zu berichten in
gleichnissen mit transzendenz bezügen ja
die haben wir sehr häufig gesehen mit
interviews und der letzte aspekt der
pilger religiosität stammt von einem
übergangs pilgernden also menschen die
versuchen biografische übergänge zu
gestalten also so was wie den abschluss
des studiums und den eintritt in die
berufstätigkeit oder das ende der
berufstätigkeit und den eintritt ins
rentenalter
ja solche geografischen übergänge zu
denen viele menschen auch den jakobsweg
gehen in dem fall aber ein ganz junger
mensch ein schüler aus deutschland 18
jahre alt evangelisch sozialisiert aber
eigentlich sehr distanziert heute der
kirche gegenüber
er beschreibt folgen dass er sagt ich
glaube nicht mehr an zufall seit ich
hier gelaufen bin
zum beispiel will ich nach der schule um
lehrer zu werden muss man an der uni ein
vorpraktikum vorweisen
und das will ich in den usa an der
grundschule machen und wen treffe ich
morgens um sechs in leon an der
kathedrale
naja die direktorinnen an der
zweitbesten schule der usa die mich
einfach einlädt ihr zu schreiben weil
sie sich wahnsinnig darauf freuen würde
mich für zwei monate an ihrer schule zu
haben
das ist kein zufall das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen
irgendetwas hat diese begegnung gewollt
herbeigeführt auch das sehen wir sehr
häufig in den interviews das also nicht
nur die erlebnisse als wunder gedeutet
sondern vor allem auch die begegnungen
mit anderen pilgern als so etwas wie
eine göttliche sendung verstanden werden
interpretiert werden gedeutet werden
ja und wenn man das zusammenfasst denke
ich dann muss man über das pilgern
zunächst festhalten dass diese
religiösen motivation ja also die
explizite motivation zu sagen ich bilder
aus religiösen gründen das die
nur extrem selten vorkommt das
allerdings gleichzeitig sich religion in
vielfältiger art und weise zeigt unter
den pilgern dann also zum beispiel was
die gleichnisse angeht was die
interpretation als wunder und sendung
angeht was die nutzung kirchlicher
angebote wie gottesdienste und
pilgersegen was die kirchen als orte der
einkehr angeht ja also in vielfältiger
art und weise zeigt sich religion und
was all diesen aspekten von religion
oder von pilger religion glaube ich
gemein ist dass es eben ihre
selbstbestimmte gestaltung ja also
niemand gibt den pilgern vor wie sie
ihre religiosität auf dem jakobsweg
auszuleben haben sondern sie bestimmen
selbst wann sie kirchliche angebote
nutzen wann sie kirchen besuchen et
cetera pp und damit zum zweiten beispiel
für eine religiöse praktisch mit der ich
mich in den letzten jahren beschäftigt
habe nämlich dem fasten herrn zum fasten
habe ich im jahr 2020 also während
dieser vorösterlichen fastenzeit
zwischen aschermittwoch und ostern eine
eine online-befragung durchgeführt an
der gut 1900 menschen teilgenommen haben
und zwar eine offene befragung ja und
bei diesen offenen befragungen die also
jetzt nicht auf einer von den
forschenden ausgewählten
zufallsstichprobe beruhen muss man
natürlich immer ein bisschen schauen wer
hat denn dann eigentlich teilgenommen
natürlich freiwillig daran teilzunehmen
und da muss man sagen zu dem sample über
das wir jetzt hier sprechen dass gewisse
gruppen überrepräsentiert waren nämlich
frauen westdeutsche und bildungs affine
deutlich weniger männer als frauen im
sample nur relativ wenig ostdeutsche
relativ wenig menschen mit einem
niedrigen bildungsniveau was denke ich
für unsere zwecke aber wichtig ist und
worüber ich sehr froh bin ist dass die
kennzahlen von religiosität nämlich die
konfessionszugehörigkeit die stärke der
religiösität oder auch bestimmte fragen
der einstellung und der wertorientierung
im sample allerdings nicht verzerrt
waren sondern die waren weitestgehend
deckungsgleiche also repräsentativ in
bezug auf die gesamtbevölkerung h und
diese fragebögen der 1900 leute die hab
ich ausgewertet jetzt zunächst mal in
zwei hinsicht nämlich erstens in
hinblick darauf also wie häufig sind
bestimmte aspekte des fastens verteilt
in diesem tempel und zum anderen wie
hängen bestimmte variablen miteinander
zusammen
und wenn wir da in sample reinschauen
dann ist es so dass gute 70 prozent der
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer schon
erfahrung mit dem fasten haben ja wobei
deren überwiegende mehrheit nämlich
insgesamt 58,7 prozent sogar schon
mehrfach gefastet haben eine deutlich
kleinere teil erst einmal dann gibt es
die zweite gruppe ja deutlich kleiner
die noch nicht selbst gefastet habe aber
einen fasten interesse äußert ja und
zwar in der geringeren anzahl der fälle
ein sehr verbindliches fasten interesse
also dass die leute gesagt haben ich
habe zwar noch nie gefastet möchtest
aber unbedingt mal ausprobieren das sind
vier prozent 12,7 prozent haben eher
eine unverbindlichere sein wahres fasten
interesse und sagen ich habe noch nie
gefastet könnte es mir aber schon
vorstellen dass mal zu machen und dann
bleiben nur noch gute zehn prozent der
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer die noch
nie selbst gefastet haben und dass auch
zukünftig nicht vorhaben ja und diese
diese quote der fasten erfahrungen
innerhalb dieser studie
die deckt sich ja weitestgehend mit der
repräsentativen super stich
der dak krankenkasse die ich ihnen auf
einer der ersten folien schon gezeigt
hatte und wenn man jetzt mal ein
bisschen genauer schaut ja also welche
einflüsse ja auf diese fasten erfahrung
gibt es eigentlich also wovon ist es
abhängig ob jemand schon mal gefastet
hat dann ist zunächst mal interessant
festzustellen dass die fasten
erfahrungen von den allermeisten anderen
variablen der studie unabhängig ist das
heißt in hinblick auf die frage ob
jemand schon mal gefastet hat spielen
zum beispiel soziodemographische
merkmale keine rolle
also das alter spielt zb keine rolle das
einkommen spielt keine rolle der
bildungsgrad spielt keine rolle
ja auch die wertorientierung spielt
keine rolle die einstellung ja zu
gesellschaft und zum leben spielt keine
rolle sondern ist zeigen sich drei und
nur drei variablen die einfluss nehmen
auch die fasten erfahrung die zahlen ich
ihn mal
zunächst mal ist es das geschlecht
ja das muss man ein wenig mit vorsicht
genießen also weiter
der statistische nachweis des
zusammenhangs in bezug auf das
geschlecht relativ schwach ist aber wir
sehen es ist schon so dass von den
frauen mehr teilnehmerinnen sagen dass
sie schon mal gefastet haben nämlich
drei viertel
ja und dass die quote derjenigen dieser
gab noch nie gefastet will auch nicht
fasten sehr gering es nämlich nur 8,8
prozent bei den männern so ist es auch
die deutliche mehrheit gesagt ihr habt
schon mal gefastet nämlich gute 23 ja
aber das sind eben weniger und auch die
quote derjenigen die sagt ihr habt noch
nie gefastet will auch nicht fast
doppelt so hoch wie bei den frauen
also wie gesagt eher ein schwacher
zusammenhang aber zusammengenommen mit
dieser beobachtung dass an der studie
also auch deutlich mehr frauen als
männer teil
nun haben denke ich kann man schon sagen
dass offenbar frauen also eine höhere
affinität zum fasten haben und es eben
vielleicht sogar auch häufiger
praktizieren als männer sehr deutlich
auch statistisch gesehen sehr deutlich
ist hingegen hat der zusammenhang
zwischen fasten erfahrung und zwei
anderen variablen nämlich der konfession
und der religiosität
ja das sieht man ja auch in diesem
diagramm sehr häufig sehr deutlich ja
also im hinblick auf die konfession ist
es so dass die konfessionslosen am
seltensten über fasten erfahrung
verfügen und die muslime und muslime am
häufigsten
ja und hier haben wir so ein muster das
uns jetzt noch in bezug auf einige
andere variablen des fastens immer
wieder begegnen wird ja also ein muster
der der konfessionen ja also man könnte
fast sagen eine rangfolge aber da muss
man vorsichtig sein denke ich nicht also
und dieses muster hergeht konfessionslos
protestantisch katholisch islamisch ja
immer in dieser reihenfolge und
ähnlichen zusammenhang sehen wir dann
zwischen der fasten erfahrung und der
religiösität ja da ist es nämlich so
dass die nichtreligiösen menschen am
seltensten fasten erfahrung haben am
häufigsten es auch gar nicht vorhaben
jemals zu fasten und die stark
religiösen menschen ja die haben sogar
zu 87,2 prozent schon mindestens einmal
in ihrem leben gefastet ja also
bestimmte konfessionen und also eine
hohe religiosität scheinen also eine
höhere fasten affinität mit sich zu
bringen wobei man eben ne andersrum auch
festhalten muss dass zwei drittel der
konfessionslosen und über 35 der nicht
religiösen menschen schon mindestens
einmal in ihrem leben
gefastet haben und wenn man jetzt mal
weiter schaut und sich fragt wie fasten
die menschen eigentlich heute
dann ist denke ich ein wesentlicher
aspekt des fastens hier zunächst mal die
frage worauf verzichte ich eigentlich
während des fastens und da sticht
sozusagen eine verzichten ganz deutlich
heraus und zwar sind es die genussmittel
ja im wesentlichen süßigkeiten alkohol
auch rauchen drogen und kaffee ja also
auf diese genussmittel verzichten die
meisten menschen während des fastens mit
übrigens interessanten unterschieden
zwischen den pfosten erfahrenen die das
also tatsächlich schon gemacht haben und
den fasten interessierten die das erst
noch vorhaben
es ist nämlich so dass die fasten
interessierten deutlich häufiger sagen
ich möchte eigentlich mal für eine zweit
auf süßigkeiten verzichten als dass die
fasten erfahrenen tatsächlich schon
gemacht haben und beim alkohol ist genau
umgekehrt da möchten weniger menschen
darauf verzichten als es dann
tatsächlich tun also was vielleicht so
die these nahe liegt dass das mit dem
verzicht auf süßigkeiten für einen
längeren zeitraum gar nicht so einfach
ist eine zweite gruppe von verzichts
optionen sind dann nahrungsmittel ja
also traditionell ist es das fleisch
also da haben wir ungefähr noch ein
drittel der befragten die sagen ich habe
verzichtet
während des fastens auf fleisch oder
möchte dies tun wenn ich mal fast in
deutlich selteneren fällen sind es dann
neuerdings auch die kohlenhydrate oder
gar feste nahrung allgemein eine
interessante verzichts option finde ich
sind dann medien
also da gibt es zum einen ja dieses so
genannte daten fasten also zu sagen eine
zeitlang verzichte ich mal auf private
computer internetnutzung oder ich
verzichte mal eine zeit lang darauf
ständig auf mein smartphone zu schauen
und bei diesen daten fasten da ist
natürlich der unterschied besonders
interessant zwischen den fasten
interessierten und den fasten erfahren
denn nur 56 prozent der erfassten
erfahrenen 56 prozent haben das
tatsächlich schon mal gemacht aber über
20 prozent der erfassten interessierten
wollen das tun
ähnlich verhält es sich bei dem verzicht
auf fernsehen ja also diejenigen die es
zukünftig fastenden für die ist das ein
thema zumindest deutlich stärker als für
die die bereits gefastet haben ja so wir
haben hier offenbar es zu tun mit mit
neuen verzichts optionen ja die also
eine neue generation von fastenden
einbringt in diese tradition des fastens
und die vierte gruppe der
vollständigkeit halber auch wenn sie
zahlenmäßig eine sehr geringe rolle
spielt ist der verzicht auf
umweltschädigende verhalten also gute 3
prozent haben oder wollen während des
fastens auf autofahren verzichtet und
ähnlich viele auf den verzehr tierischer
produkte also hier gibt es ein relativ
breites spektrum innerhalb derer die
fastenden selbstbestimmt entscheiden
worauf verzichte ich eigentlich während
des fastens im diagramm hier sehen sie
jetzt eben die häufigsten option ja
insgesamt haben sich in der befragung
aber nein nur ein noch viel größeres
spektrum gezeigt also genannt wurden zum
beispiel in bezug auf die ernährung auch
kloten fett salz fastfood softdrinks
frühstück abendbrot wollen die leute
verzichten ja oder in bezug auf
bestimmte verhaltensweisen wollen sie
verzichten auf shoppen auf
restaurantbesuche auffliegen auf plastik
auf produkte von nestlé und in bezug auf
bestimmte eigenschaften wollen sie
verzichten auf hektik sie wollen
verzichten auf lästern auf meckern auf
lügen auf die benutzung von aufzügen und
rolltreppen auf sex und masturbation ja
also ein sehr breites spektrum von
verzichts optionen im spätmodernen
fasten praktiken und ein anderer aspekt
wenn es uns noch um die frage geht wie
gestalten die menschen eigentlich heute
ihr fasten ja ist
sind denke ich zwei fragen nämlich zum
einen dann fasste ich also vor allen
dingen fasste ich während so einer
traditionellen fastenzeit wie vor ostern
oder im ramadan oder fasste ich sonst
irgendwann selbst bestimmt im jahr und
zum anderen fasste ich alleine oder
zusammen mit anderen menschen und da ist
eine sache interessant wenn man die
leute erstmal nach ihrer einschätzung
fragt ja und sie fragt was glaubst du
welche welche effekte hat es wenn man
während einer traditionellen fastenzeit
fastet oder gemeinsam mit anderen fasste
dann haben wir sehr hohe
zustimmungsquoten zu den aussagen
während einer traditionellen fastenzeit
zu fasten das macht es einem leichter
leichter mit dem fasten zu beginn
leichter das fasten durchzuhalten
ja dem stimmen über 60 prozent der
befragten zu ganz ähnlich mit der frage
gemeinsames fasten auch da sagen sogar
noch ein bisschen mehr menschen
gemeinsam zu fasten macht es natürlich
leichter anzufangen und auch
durchzuhalten das die ganze fastenzeit
lang ja so viel also zudem wie die
menschen diese beiden gestaltungs
aspekte einschätzen
wenn man dann aber schaut wie sie
tatsächlich fasten dann zeigt sich ein
unterschied dann sieht man nämlich in
einem traditionellen zeitraum zu fasten
vor ostern oder im ramadan ja das tun
tatsächlich rund zwei drittel der
befragten während aber nur ein drittel
gutes drittel ja tatsächlich mit
gemeinsam mit anderen menschen fastet
man kann also sagen
heutzutage wird zwar synchron gefastet
während traditionelle fastenzeiten aber
es wird allein gefastet in der mehrzahl
und wenn wir auch hier mal eben schauen
also von welchen variablen ist jetzt
diese gestaltung der fastenzeit abhängig
dann ist sie wieder zunächst mal ich
wiederhole das weil es wichtig ist zu
verstehen
sie ist von vielen variablen nicht ab
nicht sondern genau von drei variablen
einerseits vom halter und dann auch
wieder wie eben von der konfession und
der religiosität was in bezug auf das
alter interessant ist ja es hat mich ein
bisschen überrascht ist dass vor allem
die jungen menschen während einer
traditionellen fastenzeit und gemeinsam
mit anderen fasten in den höheren
altersgruppen ist das seltene der fall
in bezug auf die konfession zeigt sich
das muster das wir eben schon mal hatten
ja konfessionslose fassten am seltensten
während der traditionellen fastenzeit
und auch am seltensten gemeinsam mit
anderen und die muslime und muslime die
tun das am häufigsten er mit abstand am
häufigsten
und dazwischen bewegen sich dann erst
die protestanten und protestanten und
dann die katholikinnen und katholiken
ganz ähnlich ja in bezug auf die
religiosität die nichtreligiösen
menschen die fasten am seltensten
nämlich nur rund die hälfte
während einer traditionellen fastenzeit
auch am seltensten gemeinsam mit anderen
und die stark religiösen menschen die
fasten doch zu seinem sehr deutlichen
anteil nämlich fast 85 prozent während
einer traditionellen fastenzeit und zu
44 4 prozent
gemeinsam mit anderen menschen ja also
auch hier ist die gestaltung des fastens
genauso wie die fasten erfahrungen
selbst unabhängig von
soziodemografischen merkmalen und von
einstellungs fragen ja da ist sie
ähnlich verteilt sondern sie ist vom
alter von der konfession und der
religiosität abhängig
was die menschen auch gefragt wurden die
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer an der
fasten studie ist warum tun sie das
herr und da sehen wir schon recht
ähnliches bild ähnlich zu den pilger
motivation über die ich eben berichtet
habe ja auch bei den erfassten
motivation ist es nämlich so dass die
subjekt bezogenen motive die sich auf
den oder die fastende selbst beziehen ja
dass die am häufigsten genannt werden
also die meisten menschen nämlich vier
fünftel ja sagen ich faste um mich
körperlich besser zu führen und gute
zwei drittel sagen ich fasten um mich
fasste um mich seelisch besser zu führen
er hat das sind die häufigsten motive
seltener aber immer doch noch
nennenswert finden sich dann
gesellschaftskritische motivation also
ein gutes viertel der befragten sagt ich
faste weil ich die konsumorientierung
unserer gesellschaft ablehne
ein knappes viertel sagt ich faste aus
ökologischen gründen religiöse
motivation und auch das ja eine
parallele zu dem pilger motivation die
werden deutlich seltener genannt ja nur
12,9 prozent der befragten stimmen der
aussage zu ich faste weil es mir meine
religion vorgibt noch ein bisschen
weniger sagen ich faste um gott näher zu
kommen und die geringste rolle die
spielen schließlich traditions-
orientiert und motivation ja also nur
8,3 prozent der befragten sagen ich
faste aus traditionellen gründen bei
menschen das schon immer machen und auch
hier sind einige unterschiede
interessant zwischen diesen fasten
fahren die schon mal gefastet haben und
den fasten interessierten die das erst
noch machen wollen
denn die subjekt bezogenen und die
gesellschaftskritischen motivation die
finden sich häufig bei der neuen
generation von fasten denn also bei den
fasten interessierten ja während sich
die religiösen und die traditionelle
fasten motivation er bei den fasten
erfahrenen die schon mal gefastet haben
finden als bei den fasten interessierten
also man kann sozusagen sehen ja es gibt
so einen wandel spätmoderne erfassten
praktiken weg von religiösen und
traditionellen hinzu subjekt bezogenen
und gesellschaftskritischen motivation
und wenn man nun schaut wovon das die
motivation abhängig dann zeigt sich
wieder dass gleich wird es lassen sich
genau drei variablen identifizieren
nämlich erneut das alter die konfession
und die religiosität ja auch hier es ist
wieder interessant dass ich eine
religiöse fasten motivation vor allen
dingen bei den jüngeren menschen findet
ja weniger erstaunt hat mich dass auch
die gesellschaftskritische fasten
motivation ja ich faste weil ich
konsumorientierung habe lehne weil ich
was für die umwelt hunde auch die findet
sich bei den jüngeren deutlich häufiger
als bei den älteren also sowohl bei den
jüngeren als auch bei den fasten
interessierten spielen diese
gesellschaftskritischen motivation eine
besondere rolle also da haben wir es
vielleicht so mit so etwas zu tun wie
einer nachwachsenden generation von
fastenden die da also neue aspekte
einbringen was konfession und
religiosität angeht überraschen die
ergebnisse nicht so sehr
ja also eine religiöse fasten motivation
die zeigt sich bei den konfessionslosen
am seltensten ja es folgen dann so
mittelfeld die protestanten und
protestanten katholikinnen und
katholiken ja und dann ein interessanter
ausschlag naja also eine religiöse
fasten motivation findet sich bei über
86 prozent der befragten muslime und
muslime und in bezug auf die liquidität
dann wieder ein ganz ähnliches bild ja
also die nichtreligiösen menschen sagen
nur selten das überrascht nicht dass sie
aus religiösen gründen fasten und die
stark religiösen bei denen ist es
immerhin gut die hälfte der befragten
die sagt ich faste tatsächlich auch aus
religiösen gründen
und jetzt noch ein letztes ergebnis der
studie dass ich gerne mit ihnen teilen
möchte nämlich die frage was folgt nur
aus dem fasten also welche effekte
hattest ja und diese effekte die
korrespondieren zunächst ganz stark mit
diesem wunsch der motivation das eigene
körperliche und seelische wohlbefinden
zu steigern ja das scheint auch
tatsächlich bei vielen der fall zu sein
also fast zwei drittel sagen ja
tatsächlich habe ich mich während des
fastens körperlich besser geführt
immerhin knapp 58 prozent sagen ja ich
habe mich auch seelisch besser gefüllt
und für uns interessant ist dass sich
bei 27 prozent also ein bisschen mehr
als einem viertel auch eine steigerung
der religiösität während des fastens
zeigt und zwar insofern dass ein gutes
viertel der befragten sagt ich habe mich
während des fastens gott näher gefühlt
also in der religionssoziologie spricht
man davon der affektiven jahr also der
emotionalen dimension von religiosität
ich fühle mich gott nahe oder eben nicht
eher seltener findet sich so eine
religiosität steigerung in der
praktischen dimension also nur 6,6
prozent der befragten sagen ich habe
während des fastens häufiger
gottesdienste besucht nur gute zehn
prozent sagen ich habe während des
fastens häufiger gebetet als ich es
normalerweise tue also dieses
zeitgenössische wenn man so will das
spät moderne fasten das scheint also nur
eine relativ geringe anbindung zu haben
an dieser traditionellen religiösen kern
praktiken des gottesdienst besucht und
des betens und die letzten zahlen ich
denke dann habe ich ihnen auch einige
seien empirie präsentiert hier ist jetzt
dann der vollständigkeit halber eben
noch die frage wovon wiederum
die effekte des fastens ab und es wird
sie nicht überraschen
ja es sind wieder die drei und nur die
drei variablen von denen es abhängt ich
habe das jetzt hier mal bezogen auf die
steigerung der religiosität ja das alter
hat wieder einen interessanten aspekt es
sind vor allem die jüngeren und die
älteren bei denen wir eine religiosität
steigerung während des fastens sehen
nicht so sehr die mittel halten und in
bezug auf die konfessionen das muster
dass ich ihn bereits erläutert habe bei
konfessionslosen sehe ich am seltensten
religions- religiosität steigerung
nämlich nur in zehn prozent der fälle
bei muslimen und muslima ist das sogar
bei über 80 prozent der fall
bei den nicht religiösen menschen sich
auch nur ganz selten religiösität
steigerung bei den stark religiösen
menschen ist es allerdings bei fast 70
prozent so dass sie während der
fastenzeit oder während des fastens noch
religiöser sind ja also da kann man
sagen es werden während des fastens vor
allem die religiöse die ohnehin schon
religiös waren
wenn wir das jetzt mal zusammenfassen
dann denke ich sind die konstanten des
spätmodernen fastens klar zu sehen ja es
sind in bezug auf die verzichts optionen
die genussmittel ja genussmittel werden
in allen untersuchten gruppen auf
genussmittel wird am häufigsten in allen
untersuchten gruppen verzichtet wir
sehen außerdem subjekt bezogene fasten
motivation ja die sticht heraus findet
sich auch in allen untersuchten gruppen
und wir sehen eine steigerung des
körperlichen wohlbefindens durch das
fasten das sind also die drei konstanten
des spätmodernen fastens und werde sehen
drei zentrale einflussfaktoren drei
faktoren von den ganz viele aspekte des
fastens abhängig sind nämlich genau
diese drei die sie hier auch sehen das
alter in teilen
vor allen dingen die konfession und die
religiosität der menschen sind es die
ihr fasten beeinflussen und fasten
erfahrungen um das noch mal raus zu
stellen
die findet sich gleich häufig in allen
untersuchten gruppen sie ist nicht
abhängig von von der von
soziodemografischen merkmalen sie ist
nicht ein
abhängig von der einstellung der
befragten man kann also sagen gefastet
wird ähnlich häufig ja in allen
altersgruppen schichten und milieus der
gesellschaft so viel also zu diesen
beiden studien die ich in den letzten
jahren durchgeführt habe zum pilgern und
zum fasten
ich hatte ja angekündigt dass wir jetzt
noch einmal überlegen sollten ja
inwiefern haben wir es auch angesichts
dieser wandlungsprozesse die ich ihnen
jetzt gesagt habe oder gezeigt habe
inwiefern haben wir es da eigentlich
noch mit religion zu tun
die frage ist nicht leicht zu
beantworten denn wenn man beantworten
möchte ob etwas religion ist oder nicht
dann müsste man zunächst ja mal eine
definition davon haben was religion denn
eigentlich ist und über eine solche
verfügung die sozialwissenschaften
letztlich nicht ja also zumindest liegt
uns keine allgemein anerkannte
definition von religion vor auf die sich
alle kolleginnen und kollegen hätten
einigen können
er ist es so dass wir es mit zwei
verschiedenen definitions ansätzen von
religionen zu tun haben die auch
zumindest gelegentlich recht stark
miteinander konkurrieren also es gibt
innerhalb der sozialwissenschaften oder
spezielleren der religionssoziologie
einerseits substanzielle definition ja
so dass sind solche definitions ansätze
die religion ja von ihren inhalten her
zu definieren versuchen ja also
vielleicht auf eine formel gebracht
würden substanzielle definition sagen
religion ist all das was sich im hier
und jetzt
also in der e-mail jens auf die
transzendenz bezieht und diese
definition haben einen sehr starken
fokus auf religiöse institution und
tradition also das sind die definitions
ansätze die auch diese kennzahlen her
indem die ich ihnen am anfang gesagt
habe kirchenmitgliedschaft zahlen die
quote der gottesdienstbesucher die quote
der regelmäßig betenden et cetera pp
also man nimmt diese traditionellen
religiösen kern praktiken und den
organisationsgrad er um über religion zu
sprechen das ist also ein eher enges
religionsverständnis das natürlich
vorteile hat also weil es mir ermöglicht
sehr eindeutig zu definieren was
religion ist und was nicht
es birgt aber auch eine gefahr nämlich
dass ich bestimmte formen der religion
oder der religiosität übersehe vor allem
also individualisierte reformen ja von
denen die schwer greifbar sind vor allem
empirisch also das was luckmann mal als
unsichtbare religion bezeichnet hat also
religion die so selbstbestimmt und so
individuell ausgeprägt ist dass ich sie
in der forschung kaum erfassen kann weil
ich gar nicht so richtig weiß wie sie
überhaupt gestaltet sein könnte die
individualisierte religion ja da haben
also substanzielle definition probleme
mit und laufen gefahr gerade diese form
zu übersehen und das sind ja vielleicht
gerade die formen die in unseren
heutigen spät modernen gesellschaften an
bedeutung gewinnen
darauf reagieren funktionale
definitionen dass also der zweite
konkurrierende definitions ansatz ja die
sagen religion ist all das was für das
individuum bestimmte funktionen erfüllt
haben verschiedene funktionen diskutiert
relativ bekannt sind diese sechs die
kaufmann beschrieben hat daher nennt
nämlich die identitätsstiftung die
moralische handlungs führung also
religion sagt mir wie ich zu handeln
habe kontingents bewältigung also vor
allen dingen die bewältigung
schicksalsschlägen sozial integration in
religionsgemeinschaften cosmi sierung
also transzendenz bezogene gleichnishaft
bedeutung der welt und die welt
distanzierung also religion ermöglicht
mir das zurücktreten
vom alltagsleben von der alltagswelt
diese sechs funktionen beschreibt
kaufmann und diese funktionalen
definitionen haben also ein sehr weites
religionsverständnis ja also man kann
sich jetzt denke ich viele soziale
settings vorstellen
diese sechs funktionen zumindest in
teilen erfüllen also die mir identität
stiften die mich irgendwo integrieren
die ja also bestimmte handlungs
führungen mit sich bringen bestimmte
handlungsanleitung und das ist das
problem ja dieses weite
religionsverständnis den funktionalen
definition haben große schwierigkeiten
damit dann noch voneinander abzugrenzen
wobei handelt es sich denn dann
eigentlich um religion und wobei nicht
mehr und deswegen würde ich dafür
plädieren und das tun viele andere
kolleginnen und kollegen auch diese
beiden ansätze zu versuchen miteinander
zu verbinden ja also wenn man über
religion religionssoziologe spricht dann
sollte man immer sowohl funktionale
aspekte von religion als auch
substanzielle aspekte mit
berücksichtigen
ja und in beiderlei hinsicht sowohl
substanziell als auch funktional haben
wir es denke ich sowohl beim pilgern als
auch beim fasten tatsächlich mit
religion zu tun wenn wir kurz diese
punkte durchgehend ja dann und zunächst
mit den substanziellen merkmalen
beginnen dann ist es so dass wir es bei
beiden praktiken mit einem religiösen
ursprung mit einer quelle zu tun haben
im fall des pilzes ist die legende dass
unter der kathedrale von santiago de
compostela sich das grab des apostels
jakobus befindet beim fasten da sind es
die die vorbilder von jesus christus und
den propheten mohammed die selbst
gefastet haben vor der göttlichen
offenbarung
auf diese ursprünge aufbauen haben sich
dann lange religiöse traditionen
etabliert ja das pilgern ist seit dem
elften jahrhundert belegt das fasten
schon seit der antike beide praktiken
werden auch heute noch kirchlich
verwaltet ja natürlich steht der
jakobspilger heute noch in gewisser
weise unter kirchlicher verwaltung zum
beispiel ist es die erzdiözese santiago
de compostela die den pilgern denn am
ende ihre bilder urkunden ausstellt oder
die katholische kirche definiert heilige
jahre
das war wenn sie neben aufgefallen ist
das waren diese ausschläge in der pilger
statistik geheim von der kirche
proklamierten heiligen jahren pilgern
nämlich nochmal gut doppelt so viele
menschen wie normal und auch das fasten
wird natürlich kirchlich verwaltet ja
also die kirchen sind es die diese
traditionellen fastenzeiten in denen ja
die meerseite fassenden fast
programmieren und es gibt eine menge
kirchliche angebot ja über pilger
andachten und pilgersegen habe ich ihn
eben als held es gibt doch kirchlicher
herbergen auf dem jakobsweg und auch in
bezug auf das fasten gibt es natürlich
bestimmte liturgien bestimmte
gottesdienstform von seiten der kirche
oder auch eine reihe von von begleit
angeboten zum beispiel reflektion
angebote während der fastenzeit also das
macht zum beispiel die evangelische
kirche mit mit ihrer kampagne 7 wochen
ohne
und auch wenn wir funktionale merkmale
von religion anschauen dann ist es denke
ich so dass diese von kaufman
beschriebenen funktionen von religion
von beidem erfüllt werden sie wirken
identitätsstiftend das haben wir bei den
pilgern gesehen auch beim fasten ist es
soweit das spät moderne fasten ja
anschluss an gesellschaftliche diskurse
ja und damit an bestimmte weltsichten
ermöglicht zum beispiel die konsumkritik
oder den umweltschutz ja beide
religiösen praktiken wirken handlungs
führend also beim pilgern ist durch
bestimmte rituale den fall auch alleine
schon durch den pilgerweg den
vorgegebenen selbst wir haben
kasten haben wir es mit bestimmten
fasten geboten zu tun ja also die
kirchen empfehlen ja dinge vor allen
dingen die katholische kirche empfiehlt
worauf ich verzichten kann vielleicht
sollte während des fastens die kirchen
programmiert eben die fastenzeiten
sowohl das pilgern als auch fasten
bieten möglichkeit der kontingenz
bewältigung das haben wir bei krisen
pilgernden gesehen die lebenskrisen auf
dem weg verarbeiten ja das ist auch beim
fasten der fall durch diese
selbstkritische reflexion von
alltagsroutinen ist das überhaupt gut
dass ich so automatisch jeden abend
süßigkeiten essen das ich so viel
alkohol trinke das sich ständig
autofahrer oder ständig auf meinem
smartphone schauer
beide praktiken wirken sozial
integrieren beim pilgern ist das ganz
offensichtlich haben von diesen
erwartungs freien gemeinschaften erzählt
ja so dieses zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl
der pilgernden auch über generationen
hinweg das ist vor allem für auszeit und
krisen präsident wichtig soziale
integration haben wir aber auch beim
fasten in selteneren fällen ja durch das
explizite gemeinsame fasten konkret mit
anderen menschen zusammen in sehr vielen
fällen aber durch dieses synchrone
fasten während traditionelle
fastenzeiten ja so man wird wenn man
während der traditionellen fastenzeit
fastet ja zum teil einer eher abstrakten
generalisierten fasten gemeinschaft weil
man weiß viele andere tun das gleiche
auch im moment mit cosmi sierung ja mit
der funktion der kostümierung haben wir
es auch in beidem zu tun wir haben dann
pilgern über die gleichnisse gesprochen
über die transzendenz bezüge
insbesondere der bilanz und übergangs
pilgern und wir haben diese religiosität
steigerung während des fastens gesehen
und auch welt distanzierung also das
zurücktreten der alltag von der
alltäglichen lebenswelt finden wir beide
mit pilgern spielt das eine ganz
wichtige rolle dass das pilgern in der
außer alltäglichkeit stattfindet das ist
denke ich die basis für vieles was dann
auf den jakobswegen passiert und welt
distanzierung oder distanzierung vom
alltag ist ja eigentlich auch dann das
worum es beim fasten letzte
nämlich für eine zeitlang zurückzutreten
von alltäglichen routinen und
gewohnheiten und dann aber auch ja
wieder ensi zurückzukehren
kurzum also meine these wäre ja wir
haben es auch heute noch sowohl beim
pilgern als auch beim fasten ganz
eindeutig mit religiösen praktiken zu
tun ja nicht nur von ihrem ursprung her
sondern auch noch von der art und weise
her wie pilgern und fasten heute gelebt
wird und wir haben es dabei mit einer
besonderen vielleicht hier aber für
unsere spät modernen gesellschaften
typischen form von religiosität zu tun
nämlich mit tatsächlich gelebte religion
ja das ist ein gelebte religion ist ein
ansatz aus dem angloamerikanischen raum
lift lutschen also ich habe ihnen jemand
das zitat mitgebracht von nancy am ende
die protagonisten dieses lift religions
hand satzes und sie plädiert sehr
eindeutig dafür dass wenn man sich heute
religion anschauen möchte heute über
religion forschen möchte dass man den
blick weiten muss dass man sich nicht
beschränken darf auf religiöse
organisationen auf religiöse tradition
wie die kirchen also die darf man auch
nicht ausklammern die gibt es und die
spielen auch eine wichtige rolle da
komme ich zurück
ja aber man darf seinen blick nicht auf
sie beschränken sondern man muss auch im
tatsächlichen leben im alltag der
menschen nach religion suchen auch wenn
sie vielleicht in individualisierter in
gewandelter form daher kommt nur dann
kann ich spätmoderne religiosität
erfassen denke dafür plädiert dieser
ansatz und er möchte damit diese zwei
konkurrierenden sichtweisen entweder
schaue ich von der institution auf
religion oder ich schau vom individuum
auf religion
das möchte er überwinden ja denn beides
hängt miteinander zusammen ja
institutionen und individuum sind auch
in bezug auf religion stark miteinander
verwoben
ja und das ist eigentlich auch klar also
natürlich ist religion heute
selbstbestimmter gestalt das haben wir
schon beim pilgern gesehen das sehen wir
aber auch bei diesen breiten spektrum
von fasten motivation und von verzichts
optionen die leute wählen selber worauf
sie verzichten sie haben je eigene
bedeutung es geht um ihren körper oder
es geht um gesellschaftskritik ganz
unterschiedliche bedeutung messen sie
dem fasten bei und die möchten sie bitte
selber bestimmen ja also das ist
natürlich individualisierte religiosität
und individualisierte formen von
religion die haben ja immer das problem
dass sie in verstärkter form mit ihrer
eigenen kontingents konfrontiert sind ja
das problem an jeglicher form der
religion ist ja dass sie nicht beweisbar
ist ja das ist ja eins gewesen merkmalen
von religion
das heißt wenn überhaupt dann kann
religion nur in ihrer evidenz gesichert
werden und das geschieht durch
gemeinschaften und institutionen also
zum beispiel kirchliche religion ja die
ist in ihre evidenz stark gesichert
insofern ich in einen gottesdienst gehen
dann erlebe ich andere menschen um mich
von denen ich sehe ja sie glauben das
gleiche und führen die gleichen
religiösen praktiken durch wie ich ja so
falsch kann es also nicht sein kann man
da denken ja und es gibt religiöse
institutionen bis hin zum vatikan also
die die dafür bürgen dass diese diese
kirchliche religion evident ist das ist
eben schwieriger wenn ich hingehe und
mir wie ulrich beck das mal gesagt hat
jeweils meine eigenen gott zusammen
bastler ja woher soll ich dann noch
wissen ob ich mir sozusagen den
richtigen gott gebastelt habe
und hier kommen religiöse institutionen
und organisationen dann wieder mittelbar
ins spiel
die nämlich stellen begriffe gegenstände
bestimmte handlungs formate bereit
auf die die individualisierten
religiösen praktiken dann zurückgreifen
ja deswegen ist es so dass die menschen
eben auf den jakobsweg pilgern gehen ja
um ihr leben zu bilanzieren ja oder
lebenskrisen zu verarbeiten oder um
übergänge rituell zu gestalten gehen sie
eben nicht irgendwo wandern also das tun
bestimmt auch viele aber viele menschen
nutzen eben den pilgerweg ja sie gehen
nicht irgendwo wandern sondern sie
treffen sich auf den jakobswegen und
deswegen sind es zwei drittel der
befragten der fast studie die sagen ich
pilgerin nicht irgendwann zu einem
selbst bestimmten zeitpunkt sondern ich
faste nicht irgendwann zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt sondern ich faste
während einer traditionellen fastenzeit
ja sie greifen also auf eine religiöse
institution auf eine tradition zurück
die von religiösen organisationen
proklamiert und verbrieft wird und auf
diese art und weise tragen die religion
die religiösen institutionen und
traditionen
trotz aller selbstbestimmtheit der
religiösen praktiken dazu bei die
evidenz der praktiken zu sichern
religiöse institutionen und individuum
sind also immer miteinander verwoben und
sollten wenn sie mich fragen nicht
getrennt voneinander betrachtet werden
und damit fasse ich noch einmal zusammen
ja wir haben denke ich in dieser online
vorlesungen gesehen also zunächst mal
dass sowohl das pilgern als auch das
fasten hohe popularität aufweisen viele
menschen tun dass immer mehr menschen
tun das und zwar unabhängig von
bestimmten milieus schichten oder
altersgruppen
wir haben auch gesehen dass es sowohl
beim pilgern als auch beim fasten so ist
das nur selten religiöse motive
fazit von den bränden und fastenden
genannt werden das tun wirklich nur
wenige gleichwohl aber zeigt sich
religiosität sowohl beim pilgern als
auch beim fasten in vielfältiger art und
weise beim pilgern haben wir gesprochen
über die gleichnisse über das deuten von
erlebnissen als bundesdeutschen von
begegnungen als sendung wir haben über
diese gefühlte berufen hat gesprochen
über pilger andachten tilger sehen
et cetera pp beim fasten haben wir vor
allem gesehen dass auch das spätmodernen
selbstbestimmte fasten im wesentlichen
beeinflusst wird von der konfession und
der religiosität ja also nicht so sehr
von anderen variablen und wir haben bei
teilen der fasten denn auch diese
religiosität steigerung gesehen also
sehr vielfältige art und weise in denen
sich religionen zeigt wir haben gesehen
sowohl beim pilgern als auch beim fasten
haben wir es mit einer ausgesprochen
hohen individuellen gestaltungs und
deutungshoheit zu tun und ich denke
diese diese individuellen
gestaltungsspielräume die sind auch eine
notwendige bedingung für die popularität
religiöser praktiken ja ich kann mir
einfach nicht vorstellen dass die
menschen in großer zahl pilgern gehen
würden wenn ihnen sozusagen eine kirche
oder eine religiöse institution
vorschreiben würde dass sie gehen und
ihnen dann auch noch sagt wie sie zu
pilgern haben ja das gilt auch fürs
fasten da kann ich es mir einfach nicht
vorstellen dass es in unserer heutigen
späten modernen gesellschaften noch
passt wenn eine organisation verbindlich
vorschreiben würde dann und dann musst
du auf diese und jene art und weise
fasten sondern ich glaube individuelle
gestaltungsspielräume sind notwendig
wenn religiöse praktiken anschlussfähig
sein sollen wenn sie erfolgreich und
populär sein sollen aber ganz zum
schluss ich auch versucht zu betonen
dass eine rein individualistische
religion auch an ihre grenzen stößt weil
sie mit ihrer eigenen kontingents
konfrontiert wird und weil sie keine
instanzen hat
dafür bürgt dass es sich um die richtige
form von religion handelt für diese
evidenz birken das können nur
institutionen und tradition ja und so
glaube ich um abschließend diese diese
these zu formulieren dass das pilgern
und das fasten heute derart populär sind
das ist auch dadurch erklärbar dass wir
es hier mit einem je spezifischen
zusammenspiel zu tun haben von
individueller gestaltung der religiösen
praktiken und von einer institutionellen
evidenz sicherung ja wenn religion in
spät modernen gesellschaften
anschlussfähig sein sollte dann muss ich
glaube ich immer beide pole adressieren
sie muss den menschen hinreichend raum
zur selbstbestimmung geben und sie muss
sich beziehen auf etabliertes und
tradiertes aber dass die evidenz der
religiösen praktiken zu sichern vermag
das ist zumindest das was ich mir in den
letzten jahren so gedacht habe als ich
die studien zum pilgern und zum fasten
durchgeführt habe ja ich hoffe damit
konnte ich ihnen den einen oder anderen
interessanten einblick geben in ein
bisschen religion soziologische
forschungen die ich in letzter zeit
betrieben habe danke ihnen sehr für die
aufmerksamkeit und wünsche ihnen einen
guten tag aus hagen viel mag